president biden finally banning russian
oil as putin's war machine ramps up
attacks on ukrainian civilians under
bipartisan pressure biden announcing a
stop to importing russian energy
but instead of promising to produce more
oil here at home
the president pointed the finger at
everybody else and doubled down on going
green
i'm going to do everything i can to
minimize putin's price hike here at home
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production the oil
and gas industry has millions of acres
leased
they have 9 000 permits to drill now
they could be drilling right now
yesterday last week last year loosening
environmental regulations are pulling
back clean energy investment won't let
me explain won't will not lower energy
prices for families
but transforming our economy to run on
electric vehicles powered by clean
energy with tax credits to help american
families winterize their homes and use
less energy that will that will help
while president biden focuses on that
americans are getting crushed by surging
gas prices the cost per gallon hitting
an all-time record of
and 17 cents with no signs of slowing
down
and vp kamala harris
doing that much better check out these
tone deaf comments while americans
suffer
imagine all the heavy-duty vehicles that
keep our supply lines strong and allow
our economy to grow imagine
that they produced zero emissions
well you all imagined it that's why
we're here today we are also announcing
funding
for yes one of my favorite topics
electric school buses
it's like she's doing a reading at
kindergarten dana
get to her in a second but
i heard some grumblings from you when
biden was blaming energy companies for
high prices
do you remember this is the thing that
drives me crazy do you remember when
they biden white house i remember the
day it was on fox news sunday and a
white house senior advisor came on and
said that it was actually republicans
who wanted to defund the police right
and i said is he saying that with a
straight face are they actually going to
try to get away with that and then they
did for a couple of weeks and then they
dropped it because it's not true the
this i feel the same way about this
energy issue as well we were already
seeing really high energy prices before
you uh russia invaded ukraine so let's
start there and if you look over the
past you can find the quotes we played
one this morning of the secretary of
energy laughing about high gas prices on
november 3rd saying wow if i had a magic
wand boy i'd love to do that over and
over again you can find administration
officials who say it's we're going to
have to go through some pain in order
for us to do what has to be done because
you know the world's going to end in 10
years because of climate change and they
basically said that higher prices were
the price that you were going to have to
pay
the whole point about the leases
the
what bothers me is
permission to make an analogy permission
granted imagine that you finance a car
okay you get a new car you finance the
car you go through all the paperwork
you're so excited but they won't give
you the keys
that's what's happening here and so they
can say well what do you mean you have
all these you could go drill tomorrow
and it's like but you i don't have the
keys you don't you have the lease but
you don't have the permit that's exactly
right the other thing i would say is
they have tried to get so much ink from
the media a sympathetic media about how
great they've been about trying to get
america off fossil fuels and basically
they're outsourcing all of their carbon
emissions to places like saudi venezuela
russia etc final thing i'd like to say
about this is when kamala harris says
just go buy a 60 000 energy electric
vehicle like what planet are they living
on the
it's like when she said that nobody saw
the omicron variant coming right so why
weren't they planning on any of these
russian sanctions on oil and gas before
why do they have to be dragged kicking
and screaming and wait for 76 of
americans to say we are willing to pay
higher prices if this is the price it's
going to
take why do they have to wait for their
poll numbers to come in and say oh
actually this is going to happen why did
you have to wait for nancy pelosi to say
no we're doing this and she was going
forward even without them so i i think
it's been um a bad day on the energy
front however it could lead to something
better and if we're pushing on an open
door and we're going to allow more
exploration in america we should go for
it we have to push pretty hard with
these guys but you know greg we've been
pushing the russian oil
import ban and they caved
maybe maybe there's a chance if the
pressure builds
uh it's what eight percent of our
imports that could easily be absorbed by
drilling more right or even like hitting
up canada for some more but i love how
joe is framing this this is a hardship
that we must accept he said defending
freedom comes at a cost and that is that
is not true that is not it's the
environmental claptrap that comes as a
cost this is not about freedom there
would be no cost if we didn't demonize
drilling if we didn't shut down
pipelines if we didn't demonize fossil
fuels so it's not about defending
ukraine it's about exposing the
destructiveness of the green of i would
say the green ideology which is part of
a larger ideology of punishment right
rich countries can handle this just pay
more gas it's the poor countries that
are going to suffer and it's going to be
poor people in the united states right
so you have twitter celebrities like
george takai and other losers who will
say you know you know you should pay
more to support ukraine but they're not
truckers they're not salesmen they're
not uber drivers this is the same
detached mentality that we found with
shutdowns right it's like
everybody could handle a shutdown if
they were in the media because we all we
did is we did our shows from our you
know our living rooms and same people
that tell us to live with it can live
with anything so that's either climate
change
covid inflation and once you see that
you can't unsee it there's an ideology
of punishment and it's that you can
handle the punishment they're above it
i saw some media today judge jeanine and
they weren't clamoring for biden to
pass out more permits and leases they
were telling americans you just got to
drive slower you know don't accelerate
too fast that's how you remember
get put on a sweater right yeah well you
know they actually referred to it as
putin's price hike oh right you know
let's make let's make the new enemy
putin as if we didn't hate the guy
enough already but look biden started
the war on energy long before putin
decided to invade ukraine and and the
the trouble with this is for anyone to
believe that this is really about russia
and the ukraine that is to actually
ignore the fact that for years this this
green left energy
constituency has been trying to get us
into electric cars one percent of
americans have electric cars i don't
care how how much about kamala wants to
go up there and laugh and giggle and say
oh imagine i feel like i'm in the middle
of a john lennon song and you know i'm
not going to drive an electric car right
away and we've got to get oil and gas
from somewhere we can do it in the
united states we already know that and
here's here's the thing that i think is
most insulting to the american people if
you really think that the people who
produce oil
are not chomping at the bit saying holy
moly it's 130 bucks a barrel i got to
get myself into this business i want to
make some money they can't even get a
permit to make a road to get to the site
where the lease takes them let alone
decide whether or not there's actually
oil or gas whether or not they can drill
i mean it's just they everything you're
doing is anti-american energy you know
the people better than most people
geraldo if you're making 50 60 grand a
year and you're filling up your car
you're talking about rich people oil
people what people i'm talking about
regular americans oh i know i do
regularly if you're making you know
that much money and you're it's spending
a hundred dollars to fill up your truck
how long can you wait for a windmill my
fear jesse is that we're burying the
lead
the lead is
no more russian blood oil that's the
lead so russia has been hit now with the
sanction the only sanction that they
truly feared was a cut off of their only
product russia after all is a is a first
world army third wheel country gas
station that's all it is it produces oil
and gas so we've hurt them we finally
have hit them where it hurts they are
killing civilians they have unleashed
this massive refugee uh crisis they have
been destroying this uh this poor
country uh
on on their border i wanted to stick it
to them and i think the president
finally has uh exxonmobil and chevron as
you know today announced that they are
increasing production in the permian
basin for exactly the reason judge
jeanine that you suggest they want to
cash in but i i also think that we have
to go with caution these are these oil
speculators are the wolves of wall
street these are the people that drove
the price of a barrel of oil down to
zero at a certain point because of their
speculation well because it's a lot of
them endemic wasn't that during the
pandemic there's a lot of profiteering
going on as my point oh and i think that
if you just say it's all about buying
not not drilling you're missing
something are you serious
sometimes
you may think me i'm serious but i am
very serious good news is mcdonald's is
pulling out of russia so no gas from
them
that's true
russians are going to get much more
healthy and much skinnier now that
that's happening hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else